Bonjour, Je m'appelle Kevin.
Je viens d'Australie Je viens vous prêter main forte.
(Rires)
Aujourd'hui, je vais vous présenter l'histoire de deux villes.
L'une s'appelle Washington, l'autre ville s'appelle Pékin.
La manière dont ces deux villes vont forger leur avenir,
l'avenir des États-Unis, et celui de la Chine,
a un impact qui dépasse ces deux nations,
et nous affecte tous,
de manières que nous n'avions jamais imaginées :
l'air que nous respirons, l'eau que nous buvons,
les poissons que nous mangeons, la qualité de nos océans,
les langues que nous parlerons à l'avenir,
nos emplois, les systèmes politiques que nous choisissons,
et bien sûr, les grandes questions de guerre ou de paix.
Regardez ce type ! C'est un Français.
Il s'appelle Napoléon.
Il y a quelques siècles,
il a fait une prédiction extraordinaire :
« La Chine est un lion qui dort.
Quand la Chine s'éveillera, le monde tremblera. »
Napoléon s'est parfois trompé.
Mais sur ce point-là, il a entièrement raison.
Parce qu'aujourd'hui, La Chine n'est pas seulement réveillée.
La Chine est debout. La Chine est en marche.
Et notre question est la suivante :
Quel est l'objectif de la Chine ?
Et quelle relation avoir avec ce géant du 21ème siècle ?
Si on regarde les faits, ils nous posent un énorme défi.
Selon les prévisions, la Chine va devenir,
quelque soit l'indice, parité pouvoir d'achat, taux de change,
la plus grande économie mondiale
au cours des 10 prochaines années.
C'est déjà la plus grande nation commerciale,
la plus grande nation exportatrice,
la plus grande nation productrice,
et celle qui émet le plus de carbone dans le monde.
Les États-Unis sont deuxième.
Donc, si la Chine devient la plus grande économie au monde,
réfléchissez à ceci :
ce sera la première fois
depuis que ce type régnait sur l'Angleterre,
Georges III, qui n'était pas un ami de Napoléon,
que la plus grande économie au monde
ne sera pas un pays anglophone,
un pays non occidental,
un pays non démocratique, et non libéral.
Et si vous ne pensez pas que ça va affecter
la manière dont le monde tournera à l'avenir,
vous avez selon moi sans doute fumé quelque chose,
même si vous n'êtes pas du Colorado. [qui a dépénalisé le cannabis]
Notre question ce soir,
est de savoir comment nous devons envisager ce méga-changement,
selon moi, le plus grand bouleversement de la première moitié du 21ème siècle ?
Ça va influencer tant de choses.
Ça va toucher à notre essence-même.
C'est en train d'arriver doucement, et inlassablement.
C'est en train d'arriver discrètement, en quelque sorte,
alors que nous nous inquiétons tous
de ce qui se passe en Ukraine, et au Moyen-Orient,
de ce qui se passe avec DAECH,
de ce que qu'il va advenir de nos économies.
C'est une révolution lente et discrète.
Un méga-bouleversement est aussi accompagné par un méga-défi.
Le méga-défi est le suivant :
ces deux grandes puissances,
la Chine et les États-Unis,
la Chine,
l'Empire du Milieu,
et les États-Unis,